[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone happy Wednesday
welcome to GameSpot live yeah it's I had
to remind myself it was Wednesday like
three times I know we had that holiday
today today we're playing the Metal Gear
Solid HD collection yes using
PlayStation now yes as you saw this is
this stream is sponsored by PlayStation
now but PlayStation now lets you stream
hundreds of PlayStation games on your
ps4 or PC plus you can download a
collection of ps4 games like blood-borne
and until done you can learn more PS
now.com will give you more details on
that later but for now let's jump into
that game we're gonna show you what it's
like maybe when you when you don't have
one game input you know swell great
starter it's it's okay because that
gives me a chance to talk about how
excited I am to finally playing Metal
Gear on a live stream here it's weird
how long it's taken for it to come up
but this is it and I'm very excited this
explains everything what happened oh hey
someone probably me unchecked the game
feed for that thing but I can't believe
this we can only go up from here
it's true I'm just gonna start out
presenting jumping up so we're playing
the HD collection it has Peace Walker
mgs3 and I'm just too in it I'm gonna be
playing middle your solid to probably
gonna be sticking mostly to the tanker
chapter okay because it's my favorite
chapter to mess around in sweet and if
you're unfamiliar that's that's the one
part where you play a snake and I told
you before stream yeah you're the game
that made me fall off yeah you're you're
not you're not big in the middle you're
soda to it which it's you know boy like
three a lot I I had the problems with
the too much stealth too much time too
much stealth for me man I was living
that bandana
oh yeah in in one and also the cloak
life you know so I think it definitely
changed how I played but this is sick
your screaming the game yes we're in it
where we're going let's jump in that's
good yeah I like Metal Gear Solid 2 it's
probably one that I've played the most
okay it's really difficult to kind of
pick my favorite Metal Gear though is
Bruno Lee's favorite number two oh heck
yes see I've got your number
we're here for you we're streaming a
stream of a stream yes that's the frame
of a stream it's a busy that a
stream-ception I believe but as we
mentioned earlier you can actually
download some of the games as well not
all the games are available for download
but you know they keep adding to the
library which is pretty cool too I
almost feel like every PS Plus game
that's like free each month almost
always goes yeah yes now as well which
is good but yeah so I've got to ask if
you're if you're down for this this
intro is probably one of the hypest game
intros alright listen I've ever gotten
to take part in so you want a turn
obviously you want is that what turn it
up okay one experience
[Music]
Nicholas age be so proud
[Music]
so this also does a really good job of
kind of
that's a show right
it's like even if you were to watch this
[Music]
all of us here
[Music]
so you say riding
so very properly rings combat
[Music]
what's up OB Leo ro ro has the best game
ever made
oh I'm not the right crowd here
[Music]
yeah it's the stuff that we didn't
Williams Orchestra mixed with like your
tech stuff yeah so it kind of fits not
like any man yeah it's one of the top
themes for metal here is tubes Peace
Walker might be it just it makes you
want to like jump over a car like it's
very broke sounding yeah see like we
just saw riding the first shot of him
and he's completely covered up in a mask
so you don't even think like that's not
whoo dad who's this and then it'll
uncuttable
the Asians we're both sneaking
[Music]
solid snacks
Solid Snake uses solace
best bucks in all of you
two hundred percent solid taxes man I
wish this song was still around without
cocking pity shoot ya see when he was
singing together
[Music]
well yeah but turns out
that's not the case anyway that's the
ritual out of the way
I'm jumping in all right let's do it
it's a doodoo game just do tanker
because I'm probably not gonna make it
to the plants I'm just gonna do it on
normal for some have anything to prove
yep radar type 2 because it's the
default all right let's do the Hudson
River you ready let's do it all right
I'm down I know you've been excited for
this this this coming week no Ellenson
River two years ago you had classified
intelligence that a new type of metal
gear was scheduled for transport the
whole thing stank the whole thing stay
knows about comes cold not too long
quite a bit the only snake we respect Oh
William jr. played this on ps2 og right
here heck yeah that's an original gamer
hi gangster I'll try not to talk around
when dialogue happens but stuff like
this I feel like is fair game
that's also an older game if I talk over
something I'm sorry
I think it's total do whatever I think
it's fine we all we all know we all know
what's going on but I remember
specifically I didn't have a ps2 in this
came out and I was already big up on
you're solid the first time I ever saw
it was my cousin playing oh yeah and I
was like this is this is wild this is
crazy
[Music]
I still think arts that holds a parade
for the state but I end up actually
playing Metal Gear Solid 2 for the first
time through on xbox which felt wrong
that's kind of interesting way that for
your first time in the in the substance
version so that was kind of a weird deal
for me but everyone loving that David
Hayter voice yeah yeah I remember the
ps2 I didn't wait no I had to have
either rented this game or something
because I definitely played it and I was
like oh this isn't for some reason I
can't get into this one
but yeah I remember how cool the ps2 was
compared to the ps1 just in
aesthetically oh yeah like oh this is
cool like I'm liking it so Dominic Ross
goose says we'll just be one kiss well
we're actually playing on a ps4 which is
one of the benefits of yes yes now is
the fact that you can stream it onto
your ps4 and play it on your ps4 so very
into any excuse to play Metal Gear
[Music]
yeah
greatest intro ever a love that he
somehow manages to land so hard on the
ship below that it just breaks his
stealth camo and you're like I guess
that's it
oh don't mind me
also for people who haven't played this
in a big fans of smash his three-point
landing is the missus the inspiration
for his influence which lights see he
pulls himself up and he's got all the
electricity around them good look at you
pulling it to modern day you've got to
find all the ways you can bring this in
that you can Michael okey
everyone is here yeah it's like that
it's like terminator when you like I
poured it in except he's got clothes
which I think that might be where they
pulled that from history was a big fan
of movies oh yeah I know yeah that's
true he pulls a lot of inspiration from
them cuz that's the feel I got there of
him just kind of like crouched down with
all the like you know lightning
electricity around him revolver like
looking through his binoculars he's
still spinning his gun no the best is
when Matt's in the pit and he's got a
little comb that he's got the little go
what are you doing man oh that your
combs we've got a lot of good metal here
we're actually doing a play through this
series in the speed zone right now
oh really every every Thursday oh not in
Metal Gear Thursdays you can go check it
out we month doing it tomorrow
if you want to stop by which one are you
guys aren't or into right now on the
plant chapter about tween disarm all the
bombs for Peter Stillman
yeah yeah we're considering the time
this is snake you can do I've always
wanted to know the origin story of the
philanthropy x36 nice place a please
I'll pay you the money is to change my
name from juice and gem if you're
listening please let me pay to change my
name because I need that x360 nicely the
first ones free but I'm almost willing
to I'm willing to pay ten dollars I
think that's that's my hard limit though
ten I will not pay more than ten to
change my name
I'm so embarrassed by my name I'd be
willing to pay like don't you don't
actually do that that's how best for
them all right
he smells and reeks of desperation it's
me what's up Daniel Maori from Lima Peru
he's good to Fred he said their
favourite game is here something to
bring it back or maybe it's hard to
justify streaming old is it at this
point like three or the same very good I
snuck him in my stomach
oh I love us here's the digital camera
tag it works almost the same way as your
old one here you've spent a hundred
dollars vet named Bob Jones if they if I
got a one-time offer for only me to do
it I'd probably yeah I can see that look
again we're giving them bad ideas but
yeah I agree that like if you they don't
look again it's me it's me your boy
desperation Jim let's give the input lag
in a second but francisco's Ashley so I
was gonna say the the interesting thing
so far is there's a lot of like rain
effects going around and it's still kind
of clear even so we are eventually gonna
replace Bob blood worn like down the
road and there's one of the streams and
when I played it was fine like I didn't
have really any noticeable wouldn't
think there were anything but no rocks
or like you know if I dodged it wasn't
dodging kind of thing it is like it's
not gonna be perfect as you mentioned
but it's definitely very like playable
in water 100 as medical we do dislike
all this rain which is maybe is a no
that's just the game doing it's negative
but it is really impressive to think
about yeah it's pretty crazy yes so
Christian Phillips we are playing via
PlayStation now right now we're
streaming the game on a stream but there
are game titles that are downloadable as
you well for PS now so you know if I do
that at some point you're currently on
your ps4 yes when you can technically
play it on PC PC it gives you a startup
thing when you first launch a game
that's okay
you can do it
[Music]
this beam is so specific man's good a
man okay
it's very true
I like that guy I can't believe it
they've got my favorite gun Otacon
Russians first you sure no Marine barber
touched that head of hair
[Laughter]
and if you weren't sure here's the hats
just lay it on even further
take a picture snake this is my favorite
snake look outside of the smirk in three
when he kind of slowly turns around like
ah here we go
I can't believe it they've already taken
it Russian shopper killer whale we need
to get a fix on who they are
judging by their transport aren't they
some kind of military commandos not
necessarily it could be the civil model
yeah
the interesting thing too about the
point chapter after this a lot of people
even after they play this game don't
realize that the whole point of riders
like existence is to prove that like
soldiers trained through virtual
training on the car I'm not saying it's
not the same experiences actually and
the program is literally meant to train
people to be Solid Snake and it's all
just a simulation there's only one and
now we're in it and now we're moving and
it still holding up pretty well with all
the rain guard this guy
hello go to sleep it's slowly drag them
away not leave evidence behind
exactly oh well we'll throw them
overboard - just for fun well let's not
tell you drag people you have to like
you have to kind of do that because the
the animation for actually like
finishing them is it's a little bit
longer than I'd like to stay out in the
open floor
yeah I'm just dropping my converse is
the only question is why why what though
why play Metal Gear have you I don't
know I understand that Sakura I don't
know if that's this question that's why
I said why is very ambiguous that's fair
I guess but your assumption is why Metal
Gear why not know why not Metal Gear
that's my question to you Hersh marish
says actually like mgs 2's graphic best
preferred Twin Snakes over the original
but I was an n64 guy I only watched my
cousin's play the original so how how
hard do I want to go in the Easter Egg
paint here cuz there's some there's some
things involving coasters today and I'll
leave it up yeah yeah I hey I defer to
you your you're my expert here I mean
they're good but like I defer to you I
know it might be like it like a to
Javert which scenario is that like it I
don't think so you don't think so yeah
all right I think it cuz like you can do
like a seat okay you'd be like yeah
that's enough that's enough that's
enough yeah I think that's okay we'll
just leave it there that's that's fine
yeah well they're a whole bunch more
dirty already smooched yeah good wonder
if I can actually get the
there we go what was that what's I see
an arm I can't believe this if you
actually come over here too quickly
he'll end up seeing your your footprints
cuz your feet are so wet
that's the thing you should just drop in
a second
Oh we're blocking we're totally blocked
their radar but that's okay yeah no big
deal
we the radar is not as important as the
life meter I love this it disappears
half the time just put them over here
it's okay
well smoochy-smooch yeah man you got
some great emoticons there no way I saw
with a bang and a revolver but you know
Arnie we're just streaming it via PS now
so if you guys are tuning in we're
checking out the Metal Gear Solid HD
collection via the streaming service on
the PlayStation platform called PS now
it's pretty cool check that out if you
want to more details for that on PS
now.com it does it doesn't feel like I'm
like not playing it on if you had a disc
in no way yeah but that's the fastest so
the crotch region the head region are
all good places all in there bill
they're very vulnerable there yeah
thanks Nick
snakes snake knows what he's about
also it's all building up towards a
thing okay question mark why or okay
Dada why would you kiss a poster snakes
a lonely man so that's the interesting
thing about snake that I think human
eyes isn't really well is the fact that
it's it's cool because big boss is
supposed to be the real person and he's
kind of like cold and detached but snake
is the clone and he's got all like the
like he hits on me laying oh come here
he smooches posters this guy's gonna die
crap we're good it's fine
and they let you kind of do that weird
stuff and it kind of kind of fills out
his character a bit I'm kind of really
into it this is on normal you say yeah
it's just normal I'm not trying to like
do anything too crazy it's more of like
it I guess I'm showing off some of the
the cool weird Easter Egg II things cuz
I love doing this this chapter to kind
of do that my favorite Easter Egg in the
entire series is actually towards the
end of it and I'm excited to get to
there we're gonna make it oh we're gonna
make it oh we're gonna make it alright I
do get to embarrass myself with this
fight against Olga though I'm looking
forward to that so I'm not very good at
the boss fights not now no I can't
listen to you to talk to me the
cardboard box baby very important tool
and give you a cool trick cause you said
yourself that one of the things that
kind of got you in this game was the
having a stealth a lot yeah these guys
gonna hold on I'm just gonna bring them
back over here so I can show you this
this is a special this is my patented
technique okay is it the band special
say you need to take care of someone you
can use this box I'm just going to lean
over here after he kicks it so we can
see inside of it it's chilling you can
move his gun by moving the camera around
which is real weird watch this
she picks up the box there's nothing
there
oh my goodness so magic what people
don't know is when the soldier picks up
the box it actually obscures his field
of vision so he can't see anything
around him at all and it makes it really
just sneak past him not that guy though
not yet or you did that up we got a plan
that was on purpose we got we got a
point here this is fine what happened to
you freeze
no heck yeah we do dang that guy had a
party yeah I did somebody interesting
trying to time this with the bodies down
there get jammed you I can't see me
didn't even see me
good job beard me I think it's a real
good job says retro grad was a cardboard
box is a cardboard box emo these are
this is perfect we showed us three
metals got a stream metal gear all the
time now take oh man
these helicopter guy says he got all the
good genes and I got to all the lame-ass
gene said widget shank it's true as a
direct quote Carlos who said this game
is amazing
packing spot is just running on ps3
hardware in the cloud I think so because
the game isn't on ps4 and actually
there's a ps3 notification pops up as
soon as the game starts up so I think it
is just remotely playing off on the ps3
that's sick we live in a we live in a
heck of the time yeah man used to have
to go to those blockbusters warehouse
does have a rental place in it just so I
could go on a Friday return it on a
Sunday kind of beat a game and hope that
I beat the game but I was a terrible
scrub when I was a kid it's like mom I
didn't get that far
we gotta rent it again what's my name my
name is Ben that's Ben Janka I'm Eric
teh beard man's fine too I'm gonna do it
thank you all for tuning into game
spotlight
we appreciate live a lemon a.m. Pacific
Standard Time Monday to Friday see I got
off that every day trying to get off
that everyday it's a difficult thing to
get like the the perfect promo down for
sure but once you get it it's there Eric
let Ben play more yeah Kazan totally up
to one week schedule yeah you guys
played and thunk on Yakuza kiwami piece
TV and I'm still trying to like can you
get this on ps4 you can if you played
the xes now the FPS now is the sorry for
my french - hey deployment do what you
got to do assistance anyway
the actual middle huh I don't jab Z this
one's not downloadable right this is
just a stream only yeah you just stream
only I didn't see an option yeah so if
you if you do end up going to PS now
calm or if you do have it installed
you'll see the games have the option if
they're available for download see you
download and if they don't then you you
obviously have to scream it so this is
one of those streamable ones
I just realized I went out into this
fight and I haven't saved oh I'm fine
Joe Vince Key says then you should get a
YouTube channel and play this game I
love to watch oh dang been one shot this
I'm sure I'll one shot it if worse comes
to worst I'll just tank it down with all
the rations I have GameSpot Europe when
we do have a Tamar's out there Dave
Jewett's out there Oscar dais will
Potter okay gonna walk yeah Adam Mason
there you go
we kind of we stole Lucy from them
Lucy's here now oh thanks gray fox I'm
really surprised they let me get away
with writing that about dr. John 64
sites I think I might have another one
coming up for all go back to pop up it's
true like how everyone ignores you I'm
sorry the God of War no you know why
because the point he made I was like
based off of his username it doesn't
make sense
he was upset that there's like all these
remakes and things like that it was like
there's been remakes of the God of War
sir there have been some some pretty
good ones the game was really perfect
also you have to realize I think with
the HD remakes and collections it gives
the ability for those who haven't played
it yet to jump in and play like yeah
it's pretty big deal I think I mean you
don't have to buy it if you know what
but or you can just you don't have to
buy this one you can just wash your gun
overboard stream a bunch of games yeah
or download them she's got another gun
so they always have two guns I haven't
done like zooming stuff you look it's
I'm all natural Wanderers doesn't even
budge take your weapon toss it over the
flame surprise surprise you wouldn't
have guessed that
what else you got
there toss it over you know what you can
cry because that's what he would do yeah
you can even take that opportunity what
an amateur [ __ ] she's gonna have a real
cool trick coming up one that even has a
name Scout knife with the surprise
haven't seen that trick in a long time
no one's ever dodged that shot of mine
oh we get lucky like three times it's
true there is some luck that happens all
right I'm gonna go over here skits I
forgot she keeps interrupting you in the
middle of the fight remember her firing
with you other than the one shot star
there you go it's gonna shoot these
ahead of time okay why right in the butt
now you're blind you're not stopping do
you know how many things I've stopped
it's a few flippant I've taken out
literal helicopters play today I was
never really good at this well it's not
easy it's true being cheesy doing there
we go like Rainbow six siege a little
peeking I'm gonna get some good head
shots actually Thank You Brenda
oh my god okay it's okay
sometimes she just good look at that I
saw the red dot I saw the red dot yeah
she's doing the the things you did to
her okay headshot so that's the roughest
part of this whole thing you don't have
to watch me fight anymore Blastoise all
right that's fine I would have died
probably it's always been a weird
relationship cuz I love metal gear so
much but I'm also not super great at it
I didn't matter I had to be great at
again just because you like it
yeah that's fair uh Jonathan Rawley we
have pretty good internet here in the
office it is stable I don't did you have
did you feel any latency while you're
playing then I didn't feel too bad a
latency I'm also just kind of bad at
getting shots on things that are moving
around because I think that's just the
nature of first-person shooting in your
solitude yeah we got it one person that
doesn't like to and likes one in three
more that's very sweet
type II you can you can like metal gears
lock as long as like metal gear and down
let's see no leaf it's run gasps bang
gun there's a lot going on no more and
no more typing they're just typing in
Emoto emotes ritual grass that's nice
[ __ ] collection on and closer copy
well so is this
cuz they aren't a code for the original
wall to find out in MSX games they're
included in three cuz it's like a half a
subsistence version so that's right on
the main menu I think the only thing
that you're missing is the code for mgs
one is also like five or ten dollars I
mean the cipher I love to insight 40 no
army first the Marines then the Russians
now the army
there it is snakes upbeat this isn't got
that cipher hanging out snake there's
something I
to tell you preg not usual now did you
find out that tranquilizers also bear
she's very very strong this much is true
a step-sister we have different parents
I only knew her for two years you've
never mentioned her before
so the sender of the tip was okay say I
didn't want to make it myself look like
an idiot
Richard guysit's ever pulled them
renowned detectives like that's one
piece oh shoot and it is one piece there
you go just want to make sure you know
I'll lose my animate fredbear's now that
I have you think you've got some pretty
pretty solid animaker I don't know one
system to get confirmation if you're
playing the MGS games where should you
start maybe I was good enough Oh Lise
order I can take because even though
like s3 is a pretty cool that comes out
first a third game in a series 3d
versions it's still kind of alludes to 1
& 2 I feel like playing them in release
order also kind of helps you get through
the improvements of the ad which is
really nice but that's that's my thing
well people who would argue going the
actual time timeline order yeah release
order through and through also I love
that you can do that go to sleep
and he could smile
got to have some type of cred oh if only
we had a Metal Gear game coming out so
we could do a history of metal here Bob
Jones I would love to do that yeah I
can't wait to sit in of VO booth with
John Luke for two hours while he hears
me ramble on about Metal Gear
I heard the dmc-12 a while yeah DMC is
there's a lot to cover I think that's
the next one right I think yeah so if
you guys are curious we do a
long-standing series there don't leak
those in tandem with tandem we're with
multiple people collaborating pop
history up and the next one is going out
next one this guy
and he's quick he's real fast see you
over there
Stephon Smith I didn't step in there
Steven maybe I'm just over complicating
it but saying honestly thinking players
your play release order as well then
have them play chronologically wet box I
like my other sounds that they make a
lot no cure survive is the best
what kind of troll joke are you making
Hyuk Rooney's I actually played through
that game and I did
bless your heart Oh bless bless your
Metal Gear loving heart I hate I hate
that both endings that game could be
canon it's the worst part of it oh
really yeah Stefan yep alright this guy
come over here we'll do our box trick
again we can only have to worry about
that other guy I can just crawl
underneath the the lasers too
you just do that oh what's this box the
orange my favorite brands don't mind if
I do right up in here pretty dark not
now snake there are lasers there I think
I can just yeah it's so good you know
what I am gonna do though yeah I know I
know this I'm just gonna forget Olga's
dog tag that's fine we're not we're not
doing a dog tag run otherwise be I'd be
about it but game guys says just hold
them up and hit him in the crotch it's
true I'm not very reliable at punching
people in the crotch though Leo I'm not
sure when they actually added it to the
PS now list but it's available
playstation I think it's a newer one
okay I mean I guess I could look that up
I do have a literal computer here snake
you of course know the saying one for
all all for one no I know this all of a
sudden oh I figured you need a lot of
motivation so I came prepared once which
is from the three musketeers the book
and right it means that if you go up
against everyone by your speed run
getting up on YouTube I think we're
gonna do dog tag percent of Metal Gear
Solid 2 you guys ready avoid
confrontations well I might have been
yeah it's definitely newer so it was
part of the February of goals from life
yes blog but you sure you got it
yeah so if you guys didn't know we are
playing the Metal Gear Solid HD
collection we have the PS now I guess if
you wanna call it that and we're
streaming it because this game isn't
actually downloadable so but that
doesn't mean that other games on the
service alright there's a there's a
bunch that you could play through so
yeah check that out if you want to get
more details PS now calm Ben is making
his way through I am we're lost defeated
the downstairs we're gonna find that
Metal Gear yeah play on Xtreme freeze
said to make sure are you yes there's a
60fps it feels like it's it's definitely
more than like 30 or 50 it probably is
just 60 it's very very smooth come back
not done with you yet
Oh nailed it yeah we're basically
streaming a stream in a way
see I don't think this is the side that
I can actually go around what is good
thank goodness
can you intro fees yes because I believe
it just signs you in and it starts
playing what's that it's a silk or even
what is he doing here
just kidding it's a cute little toy just
hanging out and if you shoot it it
shoots you
scary he dead put him back for the next
person didn't eat anyone else - yeah
someone went through all the trouble and
we just done did it up by why I wire
this guy
we're pretty good at that I like there's
a point in time where I was like oh the
coolest thing it's going through metal
gear without using any guns so I've
tried to learn how to do like punching
so if you want to try PS now there's a 7
day free trial
I believe it's $19.99 a month or think
$99.99 for the year or you can do the 3
months for $44.99 you can find all this
information out
I can't jump over that one
freeze
found you
let's just grab this guy
how much does pure snow come on if
you're only doing one then it's a 1999
as motion should have followed through
three months of $44.99 for the year 9999
but you could try the trial for several
hey Ben what is your favorite metal gear
that's a that's a fun question to answer
because I can't ever give a straight
answer
I love one because it got me into the
series I love to because I played it the
most I love three because it's got a
fantastic story and big bosses real
badass because the answers a lot of
questions and there's a lot of
fanservice it's probably the most
fanservice II of the games Joey
unfortunately you can't download the
games there are some games that I've
mentioned that are downloadable and that
options there if you're in the service
yeah that's a pretty dope shield that he
has yeah right it's like modern like a
you know a fancy ass riot shield it's
all clear and it has like a light on it
it's just gonna hang out for a baby who
says I remember how disappointed I was
when I had to play as right in the hell
is this guy
Yeah right and the the best thing is to
as you're starting up the plant chapter
Quinton Flynn actually tries to sound
like David Hayter which is it's kind of
funny like looking back at it cuz he's
trying to still fool everyone oh my god
Rob's child is here oh heck yeah the
slappy noodle and so long yeah the Game
Boy Color version was a metal gear guide
a ghost Babel that's the one because is
Resident Evil Gaiden that was on the
Gameboy but yeah ghost Babel is really
good too
alright everyone clear out here in a
second we can continue on our journey
through this
[Music]
good
it's a good thing I went out this side
cuz that guy's tearing down through here
look at him go Yeah right
there was nothing
this guy's and on our tiptoes the soft
spot the gluteus maximus the softest
part of the man well it doesn't make
sense though because uh okay yeah yeah
but we're not I've known that they would
put a poster there but sure does there's
a lot of us happy to work here every
night you know well yeah I mean like
yeah when you get these shots at the the
doctor's office day sometimes you know
it's faster
I forgot that about
dad traded me in for a free copy of
fortnight your dad would never trade you
for fortnight now your dad might have
traded you for Apex lifx legends yeah
there you go
that's the thing
commander Jana Shepard says per your
recommendation played yeah Kezia zero oh
heck you have it hopefully getting it to
the Yakuza kiwami soon I'm glad you're
enjoying it sure you're about to embark
on a wild journey with some of the bests
best characters you might see in the
game gray fox says before release Tajima
did an excellent job of hiding the fact
that 75 percent of the game was played
as rated Bryden it's okay it's it's a
it's a weird thing that the god of
thunder the god of thunder that guy got
what is this line in mgs4 he's like I'm
the lightning the rain transforms
believing me and I'll believe in you
snake ah shoot you know I shot his radio
out like an idiot I don't see my friend
down there
where's Sergey everything's fine this is
okay we're gonna leave them out people
are probably gonna find him it's
whatever
tsubame that will be anymore anymore
Metal Gear games yeah and if there are
they're not going to be in the same as
these ones breaking here this is a good
one let's get to hang out with each
other now it's real good he's gonna walk
up oh he's gonna see those people what's
the play in here we're in a box it's a
lot how does it in terms of rounds and
then we're gonna take care of this
freeze
how does a pretty far distance that I
did that freeze this is another fun part
use the real gun shoot these so they're
the sensors for the infrared lasers fun
thing now if I were really cool and
really good and played a lot of Metal
Gear all the time I would know exactly
where they are and just be able to shoot
them off I know out economy they really
telling everyone who's watching the good
work thank you all for tuning in today
as well I can't I don't have time
there's a there's a guy who forgot to
wear his pants coming up and I got to
show everyone alright that's I'm just
gonna get up real close for it this is
pretty
[Music]
this is fun this is fine
nailed it 100% why is the door hot you
know you gotta wonder sometimes it's the
engine room all sorts of things are wild
all right hopefully you never hear that
I'm not I'm not trying to get up oh I
will get a game oh I'll get one
guarantees game oh yeah maybe Chazz you
need it
it's press run to show off my favorite
Easter Egg in the entire series okay man
you are setting up for some high
expectations here it's it's high up
there man
it's very good oh right in the crotch
yeah what a horrible time top guard
coming up - by the way are we on time
for Easter egg oh yeah so this guy he's
just having a good time we're gonna let
him in out wouldn't be listening to his
what would you say was back then do you
think minidisc please probably go excuse
me I let you live don't hit me don't hit
me don't hit me don't hit me no whammies
no whammies away whoo anyway that was a
hundred percent calculated totally meant
to have that happen yeah that's what I
get for being nice and letting the guy
who just wanted to listen to his music
live next time you know better and this
time I know better
yeah we're gonna have to do some actual
shooting here in a bit I already have
full US people that's good money we did
the Vulcan Raven toy yeah he did that
already got with the book Thor the guy's
pants well we don't know but we'll find
the guy that dad I can't promise you
what do you sense is this on ps4 where
yes we're currently playing you're just
tuning in we're playing the Metal Gear
Solid H certain I get that right Metal
Gear Solid HD collection yeah
brought to you by PlayStation now and if
you want to learn more about how to do
that and play that and stream it go to
PS now as we continue the Easter egg
hunt hit me baby one more time we've got
I was like oh man I'm worried that I'm
not gonna build a mess around too much
come up here but we're we're set so it's
way older minidisc was like nine years
before oh man I think
snake just put on your box and
everything would be fine
on I get to embarrass myself with my
horrible shooting ability again you
didn't even see me I was behind the box
read the head that one guy left me I
think it's this guy and then hold on can
you start rolling Santa file yeah what a
bunch of dummies there we go like
shooting fish in a barrel just walking
right into me standing going to be crazy
Odessa training I'm crazy I thought you
were saying him standing there was
Gracie
next time we streamed yes we should
dress like him just he actually had it
been down the last time that I streamed
literally the same part of the game I
just wore that it's a heck of a time
[Music]
so good at sneaking snake this guy let's
close them in there Arthur Morgan what
are you doing in this hole soul of how
ocelots like the main character of Metal
Gear almost he's there through
everything kind of like making it all
work thanks for this fellas needed this
today oh heck yeah I'm happy were able
to help you out kinda we'll be joining
you soon
ooh the spiciest boy so I can filter
teams repented I'll yeah I enjoyed him I
said I didn't like them as much as Metal
Gear snake are you in yet have you made
it to the holds expected we've already
passed the Verrazano Bridge all right
we'll use another recovery point they
may be planning to change course know
what the exits to the deck are all
sealed what are they planning we know
we're a fringe
you're all familiar with the Shadow
Moses incident they have some serious
defenses here I doubt the recent rhinos
want to blast their way through the
Marines either not the beach ah what a
joker
I'm gonna save once I get back into the
game I think that's the power I am do
this we need four shots metal gear from
the front the front there it is there
should be a marine these are the things
he already has it doesn't have that's
it's you're mentally visualizing he's
literally showing you what it alright
alright I'm used to things going wrong
dang looks like someone's monitoring our
transmission that's right whoo I don't
have a clue so why are we still talking
then yeah but creeped me out less if
they tried to interfere with our
communications could it have something
to do with that cipher we saw maybe I've
switched the encryption protocol for our
burst transmission for now what I want
to do is use a different method for
sending these photos just in case
instead of using the codec you've got a
computer set up on site the grants
should you upload them with the hash tag
metal secret don't look I've made
arrangements so that you can send the
pictures from the machine
arrangements I hitched a ride on link 16
at aus
military's proprietary necklace oh yeah
you know overwrote a part of the system
software so I could remote install a
little app I wrote just like I have with
anything that complicated no it's pretty
simple really look all you have to do is
stand in front of the Machine and push
the action like anytime there's a thing
really break the fourth row and they're
like press the action button that's the
one that pops to masquerade okay okay so
all I have to do is push the action
button in front of the computer once I
have the pictures right
it's like intimate behave that way one
more thing the Commandant already begun
his speech but you need to get the
pictures before he's done talking I
hacked into his personal files files I
know how long speeches on accounts to
good at his job no one appreciates him
he's a calculated man real those the
photos okay with these just the photo
snake but that doesn't mean we can just
let Metal Gear be hijacked okay no oh
you know that's probably what he was
listening to him John on the east side
Boyz is that let's see wait did that
come out I feel like that's like in
early 2006 yeah but it came out in 2001
so is he
mm no no it depends wait there's a lot
of extra get Lowe's in there I know Oh
hold on there's a way there's a
Wikipedia mm - is it recorded mm so
close so close there we go okay there's
a saying that goes even a bird on high
dies ugly that's okay I love what you're
trying to do but we don't need it right
now so with any luck we can yeah
there's our boy I'm gonna make sure we
get a good shot of him this is very
important my pants for being dry-cleaned
I'm sorry sir we'll see once we pull out
real spicy move that I'm probably to
mess up okay oh my god didn't you the
speedrun or mind we did it everything's
fine we could do pull-ups and get our
strength up but I don't know if we have
time for that you know I got time to do
pull-ups to get strong
there's a lot of talking in these client
two hundred percent and then you see
here y'all just a man crawling on the
ground all their metal gears obsolete
it's not true though raisa a
mass-produced piece of garbage and Rex
is the best one you ever learned why
he's not wearing pants like I said
probably dry-cleaning you know just the
way the fortunate circumstance someone's
taking an alternate route to get through
this
I also like how to keep you on your toes
during this they do the like wow you
guys have been here for a while let's do
some neck stretches and then they start
looking all over the room you guys get
your neck stretches it's true there you
go feel great keep it limber favorite
mgs game is still the Twin Snakes we
actually did for our playthrough were
doing in the speed zone right now we
played through the Twin Snakes cuz two
people that were with us hadn't seen it
yet
the game is still a while the cutting
direction alright so this is my favorite
Easter Egg in the entire Metal Gear
series we've got this dual projector
setup and it switches every now and that
but what people might not know is that
you can go over and mess with the
projector
and you can keep messing with the
projector and if you do it enough a
venture will kick off into a cutscene
remember how many times it is exactly
but there we go and you just kind of let
it go you just like there's no reason
for this to be here but it's here okay
we obviously know what they care about
war and that's I'll watch the speech on
oh it's sweet zone is a partner office
that has like all the consoles hooked up
to a TV and we all kind of hang out
there and the end of the day sometimes
we just like play games and we're doing
a Metal Gear play I realize I'm talking
about like we actually know about it
yeah Ono now what there's two which one
do we look at
and there's my one guaranteed game over
Thanks it's just it's so dumb and
there's no reason for it to be there at
all but it's their Easter egg how do you
confirm that get your porn house off my
screen pornos it's like not even as bad
as yakuza only because it's so distorted
that you can't really see anything
anyways so oh I I called it I knew he
was gonna do it the neck thing so he
doesn't a DS so I think this is when
they all just kind of look around
randomly unless they're not gonna do it
yeah GI Joe great there you go yeah see
they'll start looking around everywhere
the neck exercise one is is where they
actually do like the synchronized this
is fine to move on I have a daughter
misery says this was always such a goofy
Easter egg but it's so much fun yeah
right I have to make sure I show it off
every time I come backwards I guess it's
like a speedrun Castlevania where you
just go faster
back back dashing or whatever so I'm
saving the the kicking for the last time
even though there are a lot more dudes
in this room just to kind of mix it up
and make sure we chokepoint going into
the next area I'm not gonna mess with
the ghost stuff too much I'm also trying
to like yeah make sure we don't take up
too much time it's still make it through
because that this the end of the tanker
chapter has a fair amount of cutscenes
[Music]
we're gonna rule the world yeah and also
we've got a we've got a show out of
Connell over pictures we've been taking
there's so little stuff we got to do
games should be fun I'd appreciate these
kinds of Easter eggs big shame I think
that's that's kind of like I really love
the idea of Metal Gear and I love the
like sneaking but not really sneaking
but I love that it doesn't take itself
too seriously
anything else expose the Xbox one but
you know checking it out through the
streaming services yeah we are in pretty
good and no mark Michael we have a good
Internet yeah I'll kind of put that out
there but still like you know I think
it's very possible for a lot of people
to have pretty good download now here
we'll be doing a couple more of these
streams down the road where some will be
downloaded some will be so that's an
alternate cutscene for when you come
into the Metal Gear room if you take
this route which is kind of cool they
take that into consideration
Oh see this is one to realize you don't
have to it's up to you everyone you can
make your own choice I don't need that
one so we just knock this one out we
don't have to sneak past this sleeping
guy cuz I don't trust myself when I do
it this guy is real fun to sneak past
because you have to here we go yeah I
like totally under is too much more than
one but I like the whole series you
could have looked for Ocelot true we got
we got to move though I'm trying to try
to make sure we we see everything that
we can what are your thoughts have Metal
Gear Rising revengeance I like it I'm
surprised they didn't do another one
yeah honest it was it was a nice like
use of the I don't want call it the
license but you know like it was a
different play I don't know I know it's
cool you do some weird things with some
of the characters are like I kind of
like the original idea for it more it
was about grey fox my boy
sweet sweet gray fox yeah
at one point I think they're also
pitching a spin-off where you play as
the boss and the Cobra unit and like
World War two I've been really into that
[Music]
what nothing what's nothing but this
isn't a photo of Metal Gear anyway sorry
but you're gonna have to go back and
shoot another set
I'll just make a backup of this one oh
the next one's I'm sorry oh I didn't
even get a good picture of it I was too
close next image so this explains a lot
not that there's anything wrong with
keeping it to yourself I mean you know
it's your life and everything but you're
going to have to no judgments dear
photos now and the next one is more of
these it's got all you think about
Hey what you like is your business just
get those metal just get those metal
it's got a note back out I didn't get it
clear we can't believe this it's really
good cuz he just starts cracking up and
laughing okay last ones coming up this
is great okay we got that though it was
up really well get those pictures in
metal gear on my desk Vulcan Raven
picking work yeah I guess we didn't get
the brunt of the Gatling gun or
something it's the that's the game you
play I guess sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't
look I'm very stealthy I have a daughter
again so the speech just repeats itself
keeps getting lost this metal gear who
did that was it you what was it why you
we're trying to listen to the general
okay okay these buttons will roll into
the cutscenes oh yeah yeah
already yeah there's a lot of cutscene
alright and if a little bit extra time
we can we can mess around maybe maybe
I'll start up three or maybe all
uploading damn this fast upload what's
that fiber yeah right out here on the
ship looks like I have your photos now
let's take a look the first image is
okay this works it's a great effect you
yeah yeah and the next one is you're a
pretty good photographer oh thank you
definitely use this left shot so what's
the last one gonna be okay that's good
the shot from the right is in the bag
okay now we have all the photos thank ya
there the speech is about to wind up
forget the photos and get out of there
now well you'd also miss her on the
casting theatre too
we got we got things we can I didn't
know you could do that well now you know
coffin cat mmm
I almost did do mgs3 but I decided to do
two because it's I've been thinking a
lot about it recently better way to do
it
Oh excellent speech my friend gift of
the silver tongue gift of the silver
tone they say it's the mark of a good
officer and of a liar and of a liar
Americans are too in love with the sound
of their own voice to speak the truth
identify yourself I'm shower Shastra
also called revolver
I am shallow shashka Ocelot also called
revolver ocelot flashbacks oh that guy I
remember you and all your low-polygon
flippin whatever's going on
what do you want this machine will be
quite useful what are you planning to do
steal this thing No Deal no no I'm
taking it back to Cali Cali
just gonna see myself out you know it's
trying to get closer he's like what's
going on why Sir Oliver Ocelot here you
know who's the best person that stealth
Sergei Kaluga because honey
nobody move
understood
I should pan over here yeah but there is
going on what is it what's going on like
one guys like aaj sure brought my pants
this ship now carries enough semtex on
its key structural points to blow it out
of the water at the touch of this button
he's bluffing at s'right no one has to
die needlessly you know he's gonna blow
that up anyway yeah
[Music]
the point of them showing up the way he
lost at the target make sure that the
show of excessive force happens you know
let them know they mean business
perfect fakers wondering how Ocelot has
his back
it's a good plot device sell it on the
streets I was raised in snezhinsk
formerly known as Chileans 70 the
nuclear research outpost what are you
talking about after the Cold War in that
my home was bought out by the Americans
stare a point to the sand story now land
friends dignity all sold to the highest
bidder the United States of America even
the technology that gave birth to these
weapons is Russian no helped by us what
do you intend to do Oh ray is the key I
regret to inform you but I have no
intention of selling Metal Gear ah as I
said I came to take this is like a
double cross or a triple cross at this
point because you lose count you really
do yes return to the Patriots
the lovely Lily low whoa you knew how's
that possible
you have you thought I was never in your
employ look of each are you stupid
liquid solidus
no hard feelings Colonel Mother Russia
can rot for like you notice come and
just now abandon her
during the Cold War he's real angry
Metal Gear only has room for one
lukovitch you and your daughter will die
here I love this his move what he does
with his company it's real good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't see him but also how they like
other guys not shot Ocelot in the back
yeah right like the general is now free
or the colonel around what he just
pushed you sir I get hurt a lot looks
like you were long overdue for a time
traitorous dog they're all still
pointing a gun at him nothing's gonna
change
six shots more than enough to kill
anything that moves
is that a bullets no way he's gonna
strike a pose
[Music]
come on military guys shoot him you
literally literally has no bullets left
it's true he's pretty good oh yes this
duels over
if you wish to live I suggest you run
now this ship is still in the lower New
York Harbor you may yet make it to shore
of you swim for your life
he wasn't bluffing
I can't believe it
apart
[Music]
don't let him get away it's too late
oh look at him
ah no problem they're all terrible a
military trained professionals can't
shoot man with 30 yards away who's
walking
oh my possess like an idol the ghosts
coming back I'm in control it's been a
wild brother like what You Know Who I am
look out vanie he got ya not so young
anymore a snake you either you're
drowning in time I know what it's like
brother
no one denied your slow realization for
the Fox type program metal gear is a
very serious series about what about how
bad war is
trust me the price of physical prodigy a
few more years and you'll be another
dead clone of the old man our raw
materials of vintage brother
Big Boss was in his late fifties when
they created his copies but I I live on
just this on you can't get rid of me
with some fun
oh it's like so much significantly
bigger than the other arms he really is
he's a muscly boy also it's all those
recessive genes how does he have the
revolver skills with a different arm its
own as is if you remember from Metal
Gear Solid 3 the revolver technique
comes from his elbow in the way that
he's still good it makes sense it's more
of a revolt they much the thought says
some guy in the room was probably like
me to this cutscene is surprisingly
allowed yeah right well there's a lot of
loud machinery starting up
nod snake I'm also remembering now it
when it's seeing rage that playing the
scheme on like extreme or whatever the
boss right at the end you have to kill
at twenty to raise it's such a such a
pain
just 22 just 22 it may hit really hard
and they jump all over the place so
that's the twist liquid had the dominant
genes get up bald man
fight me in my giant mech suit
it's they're doing good doing nothing I
can't believe it this is just
ricocheting on
I'll try my pistol this guy's like what
are you even thinking please how about
this good nothing's working these looks
over I'm like I'm not even gonna mess
with them
things pretty nimble on one leg right
now
let me say the whole liquid to control
of ocelots body throws on things I
wasn't feeling snake was stupid for
believing it I believe that in the end
it turns out that liquid was just bird
not liquid Ocelot was just pretending a
snake fell for it Atsuko yes this is on
piss now so if you have it problem big
big one a big big dangerous problem
so do like Kylie kind of show off how
this metal gear works the whole point of
it is it takes in water and then shoots
up like it's highly pressurized water as
a beam so it drinks the water up and
then it shoots
still not as cool as Rex though
surely also got rid of advanced natural
vampire thing metal gears a wild ride I
at least just anyone gave it go also if
you're gonna play Metal Gear you gonna
have to do a lot of outside reading
just swimming around his little tail
yeah
I'll just look at its size relative to
the size of the tanker like when it
stands on it here you gotta wonder
it might be oil too big where zero
oh man
to the backflip
[Music]
sitting F bless
sorry why did he want him to live and
then
thanks for hanging out of this mail is
cool later have a good sleep by a lot of
outside reading there's a lot of stuff
that isn't explained it very well or
explained out front that but you can you
can eat the tail right but like more of
a detailed yeah if you want to if you
want to understand absolutely everything
you have to a lot of outside reading
because I picked only to take a chapter
I actually get ranked on this to I as
true was crouched it was kind of folded
up mr. president
I can't believe it he's gone can you
hear me I can't believe that they killed
snake in the second game all right let's
see how you did
I used zero rations your eyes and real
close to our goal of 100 scorpion what
does that mean I think it's because I
killed a lot of people got new items
vegetal camera Holy Smoke
heck yeah sign me up save that game
upgrading yeah connect them to the
PlayStation Network how much how much
time do we have left we have two ish
minutes two ish minutes yeah what do you
want to do we can do we do one cutscene
a swab all right just because it's it's
kind of silly cutscene swap we will go
because the this is also like a partial
substance version of Metal Gear 2 so it
has like I think it has some of the VR
missions it definitely has the cutscene
theater though oh yeah she just got
snake tails and all that stuff it's some
special time that's nothing special it's
in one of these things it's not snake
tails so I don't know why I picked it
yeah let's not do that or maybe it's not
there and you have to beat the game so I
can't even do it oh that's fine that's
fine we did a pretty alright thing but
there's a cool thing where you can swap
like character models in four different
cutscenes and it gets to be really funny
sweet well thank you all for tuning into
this stream today brought to you by PS
Playstation now I want to say PS now
because I think as PS now calm so you
can check that out of PS now.com with
PlayStation now you can stream hundreds
of PS for ps3 and PS to games directly
to your console or PC with new games
being added every month in addition you
can download a collection of ps4 games
onto your console to play at any time
which reports titles like blood-borne
until dawn mortal kombat x and prey
if you want to find out more information
go to PS now calm will be back again in
I think a week or so with another stream
I think the next one is the fighting
game one
ooh nice sink so we'll be probably doing
Mortal Kombat X and some other fun
fighting game titles so we really
appreciate you guys all hang out yeah
tuning in again SWAT live again we're
live 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time or
Pacific is PDT Pacific daylight
I always say make est come their time
we'll do PDT so yeah
either way we appreciate that's Ben I'm
Eric until next time see y'all later
[Music]